have this hair and makeup and these
clothes put on me was um
felt very lucky
cruella isn't just a movie it's a high
art fashion show the costumes may be
beautiful but what major struggles did
emma stone and emma thompson face with
them how did one of these special
costumes end up riding in the london
subway those costumes and those makeup
looks are just
insane
color-wise cruella's looks do not
disappoint we've got the signature
blacks whites grays and of course red
designer jenny bevin took inspiration
from vivian westwood body map nina hagen
alexander mcqueen and galliano
we can notice that cruella's looks often
have a mask-like quality to them as for
estella her looks are simpler but they
really emphasize the power of expression
and rebellion
i hope i do
these iconic looks from the baroness are
breathtaking there are clear nods to
dior among other legendary designers
from the 50s and 60s we can also see
that her color palette lives more in the
brown and gold world an excellent
contrast to cruella's looks while the
baroness does look very high class there
is a bit of a stale and snobbish vibe to
her look making it clear that cruella is
paving the way to the future of fashion
while the outfits themselves were one
thing emma thompson confessed that she
had quite the intense experience with
what she had to wear under the costumes
emma stone got lucky this time around
and she didn't end up needing to wear a
corset something emma thompson was
definitely very jealous of she even went
so far as to call the underwear absolute
torture it's like squeezing a tube of
toothpaste in the middle we don't blame
her as if the discomfort weren't enough
if thompson needed to run to the
washroom she had to have a whole crew
that needed to accompany her to help
with what thompson calls ship's rigging
yes
she's talking about her underwear yikes
i find comfortable underwear
uncomfortable
cruella makes sure everyone knows that
not only can she kick some serious butt
but she wasn't the only one our baroness
was actually injured on set one day
shooting this scene with her foot tall
wig heels on wine and three dalmatians
in tow
yet somehow she still looks flawless
although according to thompson she had
to learn how to navigate her way around
since she was often needing to duck and
move sideways just to get through
doorways
what is going on like that that hair
your shape everything as the baroness is
like
this movie is filled with showstoppers
but there was one that took the cake and
it wasn't in the movie at all
we're talking about when the users of
the london underground were privy to a
sneak peek of the baroness why exactly
well there were traffic closures that
made thompson unable to get to set as
she normally would so she had to take
the tube with her wig makeup and costume
oh and she also had slippers on to
really finish the look
shockingly no one really paid much
attention to her if only they knew who
they were seeing
with costumes like these the actors
definitely met their match
in an interview thompson said that she
was sometimes so overwhelmed by the
powerful outfits feeling like they were
wearing her sometimes the same went for
stone who was very intimidated by how
grand her costumes were
in fact she and thompson typically spent
the first five minutes on set just
adoring and gawking at each other's
costumes she really is the
the og
it's no surprise that emma stone's
favorite costume to wear was the garbage
truck dress it is an epic piece and
driving through central london with the
train billowing behind her at 3am was no
doubt an extremely memorable experience
it's just um
it's like things you only ever imagined
and think you would actually put on your
body as for her favorite piece from the
film the dalmatian jacket how about
costume designer jenny bevin's outfit of
choice her pick wasn't for a human at
all but the rat costume on this
chihuahua
if we consider the character of estella
she would have been getting pieces from
thrift shops on a regular basis
especially before she began making money
so bevin dove right into that fact and
sourced loads of clothing for stone to
try and get a feel of what the style
would be like for the film this
thrifting got very serious with a whole
10 suitcases of clothing to try it was
very narcissistic day which is perfect
for cruella
these iconic dresses are really what
elevated the film's costumes to the next
level as they are works of art all on
their own like many pieces of art the
garbage truck dress did require some
rigging in fact the train was hung on
wires behind stone to keep everything
looking fabulous putting it on was just
like
mind-blowing in a 40-foot train of
course there's this car covering dress
featuring thousands of hand-sewn pedals
the level of detail is noteworthy as
well the shoulders of the jacket
actually have miniature horses and
carriages on them this fiery number is
unforgettable and actually inspired by
charles james's iconic tree dress
cruella is the biggest project designer
jenny bevin has ever done no small feat
considering the fact that she's been
nominated for countless awards and holds
two oscars this of course was a very
special project and since she grew up in
70s london it was a pretty perfect fit
too bevin has been working in the
costume industry for over 50 years and
this project is a definite triumph
honestly both the performances and
costumes are so good we're not sure
which one is the star this movie marks a
pretty incredible achievement for disney
we have a feeling they'll probably be in
the running for oscars with this
which costume is your favorite